It does so here is example number one. As you can see we are bullish, right? So, you can see market structure is bullish. So right here, what we have is ABCD, right? So let me mark this out like that. We have ABC and now we are on our way to create the D-Leg. So, this is the low of the B-Leg. So we wait for price to take out the low right here. And what you can
notice is if I draw out the fib you can see price can back into the 0.79 level. So now what we can do
now is look for market structure shift and you can see that price also took out this load. So this
could be a great sign. Okay? So let's drop down to 15 minute time from and look for market structure
shift and there we have our market structure shift. So let's mark out our auto
block, which is the last or first candle of the favorite gap, or it could be a
continuous bearish candles before a market structure shift. But I like to use
this method because that is a refined auto block. So my entry would be here and
And I would target probably this high right here.
So let's see how this plays out.
We get our entry during the kills on ours.
So this entry was at eight, right?
So that is a plus point.
So let's see if we hit our take profit level.
Okay, keeps them going and eventually it hits
our take profit level for eight point four one.
But I would take one to two and I would go back home
and enjoy my life.
So let me repeat this again.
Right?
So you see we have A, B, C,
price takes out this low.
Right?
Now if price takes out this low, right?
And that is okay.
We are only focusing on this low.
But however, if this low is taken out as well,
then you don't have to worry because the ABCD pattern is complete now.
Okay.
So you then look for market structure shift as I showed and yeah, I guess that's pretty much
it.
You look for market structure shift.
You target these levels.
You don't necessarily have to target the highs.
You can take part shows along the way and you should.
Okay.
But yeah, you see price, the reasoning behind this is, let me give you the reasoning behind
this.
So, when the market structure is bullish, right, when price wants to go higher, what it's
going to do is going to form a range.
So this is a range, right?
So price is going to take out liquidity from the, take out the buy site liquidity first.
And then it's going to take out the sell site liquidity.
And then it's going to move to it's original destination.
So when you are bullish, you look for something like this.
You have a purge on the buy site and then you have a purge on the sell site.
So now once price has taken liquidity from both sides of the market, then price can move
in its original destination. So let me give you guys another example.